in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen the 10 Shadows is
easily one of the most flexible
techniques in the entire series at its
full potential the user can summon
multiple shikigami few shikigami
together generate water-based attacks
electric base attacks teleport through
shadows and adapt to other curse
techniques to put it simply this power
is basically broken which is why spoiler
warning ahead it was interesting to see
the 10 Shadows go up against the number
one most broken character in the series
in today's video I'll be doing a
step-by-step explanation of exactly how
this technique pagodro in a terrifying
situation and by the end you'll
understand all the tiny details that
were easy to miss okay so in chapter 223
of the manga goju and sukuna finally
began their rematch which is something
we've been expecting since they clashed
in the early days of the anime however
one major thing that changed in the time
between these two fights is that sukuro
managed to escape from yuji's vessel and
decided to take over megami's body
Instead This gave the king of curses
full access to Mega me's 10 shadows and
over the next month he spent time
mastering the technique by gaining
control of every shikigami and learning
how to merge them together by default
this already made him the most skilled
10 Shadows user in history and against
Gojo it gave him a massive advantage
that he normally wouldn't have had now
at the start of the fight the two
strongest Sorcerers warmed up by
punching each other across Tokyo and at
this stage the only technique the suguna
uses is his own slashing ability
following that it doesn't take long for
both of them to open their domain
expansions with sukuna activating the
level and Shrine and Gojo activating his
infinite void this is the part where
things got slightly complicated so we're
gonna break it down step by step to
explain how the 10 Shadows was involved
step one usually when someone opens a
domain the main benefit is something
called the shore hit effect the shore
hit effect also known as the can't miss
effect it guarantees that if the
domain's owner makes an attack the
victim trapped inside the domain won't
be able to avoid it an example of this
came in season 1 when Drogo was pretty
helpless and he couldn't stop him
infinite void from filling his head with
endless information based on this you'd
expect that when goju and sukuna
activated their domain expansions
Whoever has the stronger domain would be
able to land a short hit attack on the
weaker one in this situation though
because the two Sorcerers were similar
in strength it wasn't possible for one
domain to just overwhelm the other
instead their domains clashing was
described as being perfectly even
meaning that Gojo's sure hit effect was
canceled by sukuna and suken's short her
effect was canceled by Gojo this is what
brings us to step 2 which is where the
10 Shadows comes in from the beginning
of the battle sukunan knew how dangerous
infinite void can be especially since he
was there when Drogo got destroyed for
that reason going into this sukuna
already had a plan for how to deal with
Gojo's domain and this strategy relied
on maharaga in case you don't know
maharaga is the most legendary and
useful shikigami in the 10 shadows as it
has the power to adapt to anything
normally the way maharaga adapts is by
receiving damage from an attack and then
allowing the wheel above its head to
turn this wheel is also known as the
Dharma chakra and once it's turned
enough times maharaga's adaptation is
fully complete from that moment onwards
he then becomes immune to the type of
attacks that he just received previously
making it impossible to kill him using
the same attacks as before
unsurprisingly sukuna's grand plan was
for maharaga to adapt to infinite void
because if that was to happen the
shikigami could destroy Gojo's domain
whenever it wants to this is how we get
to step 3 which is the process of
secretly getting maharaga to adapt in a
way that satru doesn't notice to
accomplish this the very first thing
sukuna did was make a small adjustment
to Mega me soul ever since his body was
taken over fushiguro's Soul has been
trapped in this dark place and for
sukuna this was great news by simply
placing the Dharma chakra above Mega me
soul it created a scenario where all of
the damage from goju's infinite void
would be transferred directly to
fushiguro remember a second ago I
explained that for maharaga to adapt he
needs to take damage but in this case
Megami receives the damage without
anyone else knowing while maharaga
receives the benefits of adaptation
finally step 4 is where everything comes
together because shortly after
activating his domain sukina did one
extra thing to make sure fushiguro got
hurt by Gojo's technique originally we
were told that because these two were
evenly matched their short hit attacks
would cancel each other out however in
chapter 230 we find out this wasn't
totally accurate when sukuna first
activated his malevolent Shrine he
created a loophole in which infinite
void would still be able to damage his
body and then all that damage would
instantly be transferred to Mega misol
to put it another way sukuna had tricked
Gojo into making his star pupil brain
dead without him even realizing what
he's doing now with that explained the
battle continues with the king of curses
shattering Gojo's domain from the
outside as a general rule about domain
expansions 99 of them are barriers that
are strong on the inside and weaker on
the outside sukuna is the exception to
this since his domain doesn't have a
barrier but rather whether it's more
like an open space that slices anything
inside a certain radius as a result it
was easy for him to externally slice
infinite void without the need for
maharaga's help but because Gojo has
insane amounts of curse energy he didn't
have a problem expanding his domain a
second time third time fourth time and
fifth time every time this happened
fushiguro's brain kept soaking up all
the damage from infant avoid again and
again and again enabling maharaga to
slowly adapt to Gojo's domain the only
time Mega me wasn't suffering was on the
few occasions when sukina used domain
amplification but that's a topic that
we'll be explaining later on in the
video for now all you need to know is
that on the inside of these domains Gojo
kept dominating and eventually during
satoru's fifth domain expansion he
overpowered the king of curses to the
point where sukuna got fully engulfed by
infinite void in this panel he was hit
with a hundred percent of Gojo's Shore
hair attack which wasn't the case
earlier and as a consequence he couldn't
transfer all of the damage to Mega me
with kind of being paralyzed here this
should have been the end of the battle
but before Gojo can deal a fatal blow
the Dharma chakra finishes turning with
that final turn maharaga's adaptation to
infinite void was complete and therefore
he had permission to emerge out from the
Shadows the shikigami then
single-handedly rips apart Gojo's domain
demonstrating that it's unaffected by
the usual information overloads
following this tsukuna quickly regains
Consciousness and in a moment of honesty
he reveals to go to that he knew
infinite void would be an issue and so
he made it a priority to kind of take it
off the table in that sense you could
say the king of curses succeeded given
that he now has a shikigami that can
break infinite void at will and also
Gojo who doesn't have the stamina to
open another domain for a bit of context
here whenever someone activates a domain
there's usually a cooldown period where
you can't properly use your cursed
technique this cooldown period even
applies to people like Gojo and sukuna
but saturu tried to get around it by
aggressively healing his own brain with
First cast technique doing that is what
enabled him to use domain expansion five
times in a row but the drawback here is
that he pushed himself way too far and
damaged his mind in the process
according to sukana if Gojo was to try
and use his domain a sixth time it's
likely that he'd either die or at the
very least it wouldn't be effective by
contrast the king of curses didn't have
that problem and after sending maharaga
back into the Shadows he prepares to
kill satsuru with his malevolent Shrine
let me know your thoughts on this down
below but to me based on Gojo's body
language and facial expressions it
seemed like in this moment he did
actually think he was about to lose
obviously in regular circumstances he
would never think that way but if we're
being real this isn't the face of
someone who had a solid plan to stop
malevolent Shrine anyhow luckily for him
when sukuna goes to open his domain the
entire thing immediately collapses and
this is because of the brain damage he
took from infinite void although sukuna
was only affected by it for less than 10
seconds the amount of information that
blowed into his mind was enough to
injure his brain and make it too
difficult to expand his full domain from
Gojo's perspective this was a lifesaver
and also the funniest thing he'd ever
seen in his life and after getting back
to his feet he punches sukina Square in
the face this scene was important
because if you remember back in season
one Joker mentioned that there was
something unusual about Gojo's punches
at the time we didn't really know what
he meant by this but Asuka gets attacked
we find out what makes these punches so
deadly right at the moment of contact
satoru activates blue which is an
ability that warps space and quickly
pulls things towards it by using blue at
the moment of contact it significantly
boosts the strength of the punch but
from sukuna's point of view this wasn't
actually the worst thing in the world
courtesy of the Dharma chakra above his
head every time Gojo punches him it
helps the adaptation process all sukuna
has to do is relax and just keep
receiving these attacks and eventually
once the wheel spins four times maharaga
will be totally unaffected by Blue and
infinity as they continue fighting the
Dharma chakra does then spin for the
first time but an interesting detail is
that just before it happened we can see
that the wheel turned black what this
shows is that when the wheel is gold the
adaptation process is working but when
it turns black it means that the whole
process is interrupted in this case the
reason it was interrupted is because of
inability known as domain amplification
to explain what this is we have to
acknowledge that when it comes to Gojo
his Affinity makes it impossible for
anyone to touch him therefore domain
amplification is just one of the few
ways that tsukino can get around this
and it involves surrounding his own body
with an empty domain this empty domain
then acts like a vacuum that sucks up
godro's curse technique meaning that
temporarily tsukuna is able to
physically touch him the downside
however is that while domain
amplification is active the king of
curses isn't able to use any curse
techniques including the 10 Shadows
explaining why the wheel turns black
moving on sometime after amplification
gets turned off the Dharma chakra spins
a total of three times with just one
more spin maharagu would become fully
adapted to Blue and Infinity but Gojo
was planning to kill suguna before that
could happen up until now his strategy
was to only use blue for his attacks so
that it would make it seem like he
wasn't planning to use any of his other
abilities in chapter 232 he then
successfully manages to trick zukuna by
striking him from behind with curse
technique reversal red as the name
suggests red is the opposite of blue and
it blasts things away rather than
pulling things together the end result
is that sukuna gets thrown like a
ragdoll towards Gojo followed by satru
punching him with a precise black flash
in my previous videos explaining jjk
season 1 and the jjk movie I broke down
exactly what black flash is so for this
video all I'm going to say is that it's
a distortion in space that increases the
strength of an attack by more than
double now when you factor in that Gojo
already had the strongest punches in the
series The amount of force was so
intense that it instantly knocked zukina
unconscious if you haven't been keeping
track this is now the second time he's
been put asleep and as the Dharma chakra
falls off his head it luckily spins once
it hits the ground the significance of
this fourth spin is that maharaga has
officially adapted to Blue and infinity
meaning that he can now physically touch
Gojo that's why in this panel it slashes
him clean across the chest and as you
can see there was noticeable damage
since Infinity is no longer in the way
in spite of that Gojo heals himself by
using reverse curse technique although
the speed of his regeneration is now
visibly slower than before in response
satsuru recovers some of his curse
energy by doing this thing called a
cursed chant which is basically just a
short ritual that elevates his power
once that's done he then prepares to
destroy maharaga in one go with red but
sukuna makes a move to defend his
shikigami having finally woken up from
his black flash induced coma the king of
curses Saves maharaga by sending him
into the Shadows at the exact same time
he also releases a swarm of rabbits to
distract Gojo and in case you don't know
the name of this shigami is rabbit
Escape
regardless Gojo forces maharaga to come
out of hiding by firing red directly
into the shadows and in this next panel
we see the Dharma chakra turn again the
implication here is that maharagu was
indirectly hit with red and has now
begun adapting to that ability which is
bad news for obvious reasons shortly
afterwards the fight then transitions
into a 2V1 with maharaga breaking goju's
Infinity while sukuna attacks from a
distance what was impressive about this
is the way sukuna damage Gojo because
from the sidelines he shot a high
pressure blast of water straight from
his hands the ability to shoot water
originally belonged to Max elephant so
for sukuna to harness the elephant's
power without even summoning it it's a
level of Mastery that we'd never seen
from fushiguro also the way he
positioned his hands is identical to
piercing blood which is the kamo
family's like signature move and it's
possible if not likely that sukuna took
direct inspiration from them to make
things even worse the king of curses
then merges together in a way Great
Serpent round around here and an unknown
tiger shikigami to form this Chimera
type creature known as agito personally
I think tsukune does deserve points for
creativity at least since as far as we
know adito was just an idea that he came
up with from scratch considering that
it's made from four separate shikigami
agito has a combination of their
abilities including lightning super
regeneration and a snake for a tail the
three of them then shamelessly gang up
on Gojo with maharaga having the most
important job of disabling Infinity to
deal with this situation saturu tries
once again to destroy maharaga with red
but to his surprise it barely has any
effect in fact at this point in time the
only move maharaga hasn't begun adapting
to in some way is hollow purple the
downside to Holo purple though is that
it takes a while to charge up but to win
this fight he doesn't really have many
other options a second later the
tushikigami then chased Gojo around the
city while sukuna protects himself by
hiding in the shadows in this panel we
can see that SAS True retaliates by
Smashing agito with another black flash
and then decapitating their snake on his
tail in this scene his main priority was
to kill agito before it can use its
regeneration to heal sukuna while on the
flip side souk and his main priority was
to stop godro from using Hollow purple
what happens next is that he basically
tells maharaga off not working hard
enough and so to impress his manager the
shikigami does something completely
unexpected after the Dharma shock
returns one more time it somehow enables
maharaga to copy sukuna's curse
technique and the shikigami uses this
power to slice off Gojo's right arm this
kind of slashing attack is what sukuna
refers to as dismantle and it's when the
slash travels through the air and then
Cuts its Target from a distance
regardless even with only one arm and
three monsters ganging up on him Gojo's
priority doesn't change just like before
his main goal is to kill agito and so he
punches the shikigami with blue and then
increases his curse energy to its
maximum output maximum output is the
most powerful variation of blue as it
effectively acts like a black hole that
drags things towards it even more
violently than usual the end result is
that agito gets sucked into a ball and
crushed with his super regeneration not
being fast enough to save him meanwhile
sukuna was at risk of being sucked in as
well since he hasn't adapted to Blue
hence why maharaga had to swoop in and
defend him and at this stage in the
fight the two Sorcerers had very
different feelings about how things were
going in Gojo's case he hadn't been
pushed to his limits like this since
toji and according to chapter 233 he
felt a huge sense of satisfaction at the
same time the king of curses was said to
be feeling uncomfortable for the first
time in a thousand years since it was
clear that Gojo had all of the momentum
this was shown when he heals his severed
arm with reverse curse technique uses
that new arm to punch maharagu with
black flash throws hands with sukuna and
then punches them both with his fourth
black flash of the day to do this many
black flashes is proof that he's reached
an unbelievable level of concentration
and it actually tied him with ug anonymy
for the black flash world record after
this Gojo began another cursed chant to
recover his output and based on the way
his curse energy was increasing sukina
suspected that red was about to be used
thanks to maharaga though red isn't
something that he needed to worry about
because like I said earlier the
adaptation process had already started
for that reason sukuna doesn't try to
intervene in fact he just stands there
waiting for Gojo to fire so that
Maharaja can take the hit however in a
surprising turn of events satsuru
doesn't shoot red in tsukuna's Direction
instead choosing to fire it directly
into the sky while this might seem
counter-intuitive it makes sense when we
remember that just a second ago Gojo
killed agito with blue after agito's
death the blue orb was then still
floating in the sky and if blue makes
contact with red then they merge
together to form purple of course once
sukuna realized what was going on he
sent maharaga to destroy blue before red
can make contact and ordinarily that
might have worked what's funny though is
that because maharaga had already
adapted to Blue earlier it meant that he
wasn't getting pulled towards it on the
other hand Gojo was using Blue's power
to his Advantage as it sucked him
towards it at high speeds allowing
saturu to get there first before
maharaga immediately following this Gojo
continues chanting only this time he
does the charm for hollow purple which
by itself can increase the output by up
to 80 as red and blue then Collide the
resulting blast engulfs all three of
them permanently erasing maharaga the
Dharma chakra and a large section of
Tokyo meanwhile the king of curses gets
burnt to Pieces as well as he takes so
much damage that according to kusakabe
sukina doesn't have the strength for
amplification or for Rapid healing with
reverse curse technique when you add in
the fact that he also doesn't have
maharage it leaves him in a hugely
vulnerable position as he's lost the
main benefit of the 10 Shadows technique
by contrast Gojo was mostly finances
even though he was hit by purple the
blast was made from from his own cursed
energy so as you can imagine it doesn't
hurt him as much therefore I think it's
fair to say that when it comes to Gojo
versus the 10 Shadows specifically he
did a hundred percent come out on top
regardless of what happens next between
him and tsukuna let me know your
thoughts on everything down below and if
you enjoyed this video I'd really
appreciate it if you hit the like button
to let me know if you liked it and check
out some other videos on my channel that
should be on screen right about now also
don't forget to subscribe as it would be
amazing to hit 500k Subs before the end
of the year and until the next one peace
out